have you ever had something come across  your desk so to speak metaphorically  where you just thought this is going to  ruin this person's life I can't do it oh  my God yes all the time there's a lot of  things that come that I come across that  are litigious that have to do with  celebrities and I pass those off I pass  those off to real reporters real  journalists my intention is to entertain  and build a community and that's why I  love doing what I do do you have a group  of people that are your trusted sources  where you say this isn't for me but I  feel a responsibility to pass this along  and do you have sort of a  alumni if you will that you turn to yes  so there are I have you know people that  I talk to at a variety of outlets so you  know news outlets entertainment Outlets  um that if something I come across I  think it would be better suited for a  page six or a Daily Mail like I'll pass  it off